[Music
] metro detectives investigate a
shooting that occurred in the northeast of the
valley how are you greetings cristian
casares with his brief news
now in spanish this incident happened in
jan alumni near pecos and schubert
during the early morning police report
that  three men approached a
person walking their dogs
minutes after the victim was
shot he was taken to the hospital
while authorities are
on the suspects' trail
the south nevada health district is
offering booster doses of the
vaccine against cob and 19 in all its
branches so far
these reinforcements are recommended
to people who obtained a
johnson johnson vaccine more than two months ago
for the other two vaccines you must be
in the eligibility group all those
details are  in the news now dotcom
in the spanish section the
las vegas metropolitan police department
is organizing  Hoisting a family event
to celebrate Halloween
tonight is called the Frankfurt Suite and it will be at
the Spring Valley station located
nearby, it is exaggerated and the event
will last from 6 to 8 at night and we
close this report with
temperatures as we can see
we will have a sunny day with
temperatures reaching 70 degrees in
the afternoon we will see some clouds there will be a
slight increase in temperatures
especially for the day of the witches
we will see there a day almost 77 degrees
on Sunday a
pleasant forecast  and free of rain I am Cristian
Cásseres with his new
news now in Spanish good day
[Music]